[Música]
en alguna ocasión usted se han llegado a
preguntar que es realmente lo que lleva
una persona a sobresalir positivamente
dentro de alguna actividad o quizá
aquello que produce un resultado exitoso
de alguna nueva idea un proyecto o
alguna habilidad durante varios años
éstas han sido algunas de las preguntas
más importantes de mi vida ya que desde
que yo tenía una edad aproximada de 12
años comenzó a surgir me un maravilloso
gusto por la apreciación de las artes
audiovisuales y cinematográficas fue así
como desde entonces me enfoqué en
escribir producir dirigir y editar
distintos proyectos relacionados con
todo este medio artístico proyectos que
consistían principalmente en
cortometrajes largometrajes anuncios de
publicidad vídeos de modelaje y entre
otras cosas más
a través del tiempo estos trabajos
fueron evolucionando y aumentando su
nivel de complejidad al igual que la
cantidad de personas y amigos que se
iban involucrado
dentro de todo mi equipo de trabajo fue
de la manera que haciendo todas estas
cosas todas todas estas actividades
llegó un punto en el que comencé a
preguntarme qué es aquello que conlleva
al éxito como una persona o un grupo de
personas logran sobresalir tanto dentro
de alguna actividad o en mi caso qué es
lo que yo tengo que hacer para poder
sobresalir a una mayor escala dentro de
todo este medio artístico como otros
grandes artistas del cine después de
pensarlo y pensarlo durante un largo
tiempo comencé a traducir algunas de las
respuestas que yo consideraba eran las
más apropiadas para ello aquellas
respuestas que podían explicar cómo una
persona llegaba a tener resultados
sobresalientes dentro de cualquier
actividad que realizaba y fue así como
concluir que todo este éxito era por
tres razones principales la primera por
el talento que todas estas personas
disponían ya sea físico o intelecto
segundo por los medios y materiales que
utilizaban para hacerlo y finalmente
tercero por el dinero del cual disponían
para financiar sus trabajos fue de esta
manera como llegué a creer durante mucho
tiempo que estos eran los principales
elementos necesarios para poder llegar a
tener un éxito sobresaliente dentro de
cualquier cosa pero sin darme cuenta
este hielo que llegó a perjudicar me en
lugar de motivarme y ayudarme a
continuar debido a que comencé a pensar
que para poder hacer buenos trabajos
dentro del cine y el arte audiovisual
necesitaba de antes tener el mejor
equipo el mayor financiamiento económico
ya que sin éstos no podría llegar a
tener buenos resultados y simplemente
fracasar en ello pensaba que lo más
importante era el tener que el ser
debido a que si yo tuviera el equipo de
grabación y la mayor cantidad de dinero
éstos me llevarían a más fácilmente
poder encontrar un resultado exitoso
pero no fui hasta hace varios años
cuando me di cuenta del gran error que
estaba cometiendo al pensar todo esto ya
que cuando un equipo de trabajo y yo
presentamos nuestro primer largometraje
en un evento público que nosotros mismos
organizamos me di cuenta de que a pesar
de todas las dificultades que se nos
presentaron al momento de hacerlo como
la falta de presupuesto la escasez de
equipo de grabación y muchos otros
percances aún así pudimos cumplir
nuestro objetivo de una muy buena manera
obteniendo resultados positivos a
nuestras capacidades ya nuestras
habilidades lo que nos provocó una gran
sensación de satisfacción y alegría pero
me puse a pensar si no fue el dinero ni
el equipo de grabación lo que nos llevó
realmente a mostrar nuestras capacidades
y poder cumplir nuestro objetivo
entonces que fue para poder responder de
nuevo esta pregunta tuve que volver a
analizar otros factores causantes de
esta situación pero ahora desde una
perspectiva
completamente distinta ya que
anteriormente sólo consideraba
cuestiones externas a nosotros al ser
humano y no aquello que proviene desde
nuestro interior fue de la manera que
como buscando qué pudo provocar aquel
resultado encontré algo llamado como la
fuerza de voluntad pero que es aquella
fuerza de voluntad la fuerza de voluntad
se define como aquella energía aquella
decisión y aquellas ganas que provienen
desde lo más profundo del ser humano que
nos hacen encender ese deseo de poder
cumplir una meta un proyecto o cualquier
cosa que nosotros deseemos pero
obteniendo un resultado en particular
por lo que aquello realmente produce un
efecto significativo dentro del ser
humano que nos lleva a poder obtener un
buen resultado
pero como es posible que simplemente
aquella fuerza o aquel deseo sea más
importante que el dinero los medios o el
talento para poder llegar al resultado
que estamos buscando de nuevo para poder
comprenderlo tuve que plantear una
situación para de esta manera reducirlo
y fue así como establece una persona
puede llegar a tener un inigualable
talento todo el dinero necesario o la
facilidad de los medios para hacer las
cosas pero si no tiene esa fuerza y este
gran deseo por querer desarrollarlo y
ponerlo en práctica entonces no va a
lograr aquel que aquel deseo aquel
proyecto que está buscando no va a
sobresalir dentro de ello y por lo tanto
no tendrá buenos resultados mientras que
por lo contrario una persona que tenga
que no tenga todos los recursos
anteriores pero si aquella fuerza de
voluntad combinada con una buena
disciplina la llevará de alguna forma o
de otra a poder cumplir
poco a poco su objetivo mientras que
también esto la va conduciendo a obtener
aquellos otros recursos secundarios para
cada vez ir mejorando dentro de ello
entonces ese es el verdadero secreto la
fuerza de voluntad y las ganas de hacer
las cosas sin importar los límites o los
percances que se nos puedan presentar
para cumplir un objetivo obviamente esto
acoplado a nuestras habilidades y
nuestras capacidades que presentemos en
ese momento ya que dentro de ese momento
y reforzado con una muy buena disciplina
que nosotros mismos tengamos para
cumplirla esta es la manera que nos
mantendrá firmes y constantes durante
todo este proceso la disciplina de igual
manera pero también debemos aclarar una
cosa la fuerza de voluntad no es algo
que llegue de forma automática a
nosotros más bien nosotros mismos
debemos buscarla principalmente a través
de la motivación y con aquellos
estímulos que ayuden a comprender
nuestros propósitos más internos para
poder ser coherentes
conscientes sobre lo que queremos y lo
que realmente estamos dispuestos a hacer
para poder cumplir nuestro propósito o
nuestro objetivo debido a que tendremos
que hacer algunos sacrificios de
nuestros tiempos o nuestras actividades
y deseos personales como lo había
comentado debido a que no tendremos la
facilidad de esos otros medios es por
ello que llegaremos a tener que
sacrificar un poco más de nuestros
tiempos yo es por ello que yo los invito
a todos ustedes a que busquen aquella
motivación necesaria que puedan alcanzar
y despertar esa fuerza de voluntad
dentro de su interior y así puedan
iniciar hacer todo aquello que les
apasiona a poder cumplir aquel deseo
proyecto o aquella meta en la que
siempre han estado pensando pero nunca
se han atrevido a realizar por todos los
percances o las dificultades que se
puedan presentar ya sea porque no tienen
el dinero necesario el equipo adecuado o
los mejores materiales o hasta también
el apoyo de alguien de tu familia de tus
amigos o en general verdad
pero al final todo esto llega a pasar a
segundo término cuando es realmente que
crece en ti y en lo que estás dispuesto
a hacer para trabajar disciplinadamente
y hacer y así poder cumplirlo
tal vez podrá ser un proceso más
complicado como te el documento por no
tener todas estas habilidades esas
facilidades en el momento tendremos que
dar un doble esfuerzo y sacrificar
muchas otras cosas más pero al final te
irás dando cuenta que lo más importante
no es el tener sino el ser porque
tendrás que adaptarte a tus
posibilidades e intentar distintas
maneras de llevar a cabo tu proyecto
puede decir que al inicio no tengas
precisamente los resultados que buscabas
pero podrás aprender de estos y adquirir
más conocimientos a través de la
experiencia con la disciplina y la
perseverancia que te conducirán a
resultados inimaginables así que solo
motiva te cree en ti y atrévete
[Música]